قبل ان نتوجه الى مراسلنا في جنوب الخرطوم
الطاهر المرضي ننوه الى هذا الخبر العاجل
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في احياء الصحافه وجبرا والدرجه
الاولى جنوب الخرطوم نتابع التفاصيل مع
الطاهر
نعم هنا اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع استخدمت فيها جميع انواع
الاسلحه ونحن نسمع انفجارات قويه
في هذه المنطقه تحديدا يبدو ان هذه
المساله الان
الطرفان يخوضان قتال عنيف هذا القتال
اعقبه او كان قبله بالامس ايضا
ليلا لساعات الاولى من الصباح كان هناك
ايضا اشتباكات عنيفه استخدمت فيها الاسلحه
الثقيله كان هنالك تحليق للطيران
تحليق للطيران في هذه المنطقه الجيش
يسير لتمشيط هذه الثقه واخراج قوات منها
بشكل نهائي ولكن ما نسمعه الان من
اسلحه
واشتباكات تدل على ان المعركه في في في
ذروتها يعني خاصه وان الان الامور
للتصعيد اكثر بما انها تتجه للهدنه على
الرغم من ان الطرفان اعلنوا هذه الهدنه
وليس هنالك اي التزام هذه اليوم في هذا
اليوم الاشتباكات اكبر مما كانت عليه في
الهدنه السابقه وهذا يدل على ان الامور
يعني ليست هناك اي
احتمال لوقف لاطلاق النار ما اهميه هذه
الاحياء التي تتركز فيها هذه المواجهات هل
من مقرات عسكريه مقرات لقوات الدعم السريع
نعم هذه المناطق المذكوره وان كان في
صحافات الجبراء ولا في اتجاه المدينه
الرياضيه جنوب الخرطوم كلها يوجد تواجد
كبير لقوات الدعم السريع مراكز في هذه
المناطق وبالتالي كان بالامس هنالك
استهداف لاحدى هذه المعسكرات في الجنوب
شرق الخرطوم
الليله وفي الصباح الباكر وهذه الشبكات
تسجيل الان مستمره في هذه المناطق
بعنف
وهنالك ايضا يعني حتى الاهالي او
المواطنين في هذه المنطقه البعض منهم حاول
الخروج من هذه المنطقه لانهم يصبحوا في
مرمى النيران ويخافون ايضا تخوفون من ان
تكون هنالك يعني سقوط قذائف ودانات في
منازلهم
اسماعيل تسمعين معي اذا كنت تسمع صوت
الانفجارات بشكل كبير في هذه المنطقه